同学们好，今天我们拉片皮克斯经典动画玩具总动员。第一部玩具总动员是1995年由迪士尼和皮克斯工作室合作推出的动画长片，也是影史第一部完全以计算机三维动画制作的长篇剧情动画片。如果说威力号弃船，赋予了动画片声音。白雪公主赋予了动画片色彩，那这部玩具总动员就是开启了动画片3D时代的作品了，导演约翰拉塞特也因此获得了奥斯卡历史上第一个颁给动画电影的特别成就奖。
接下来我会带同学们从创作者的角度剖析学习这部开创了3D动画电影历史先河的悠久电影。
。
咱们今天是拉片课啊，拉片课相信上节课听过的同学都知道，拉片儿课里面可以快速的验证和实践你在课上学过的知识，对不对？
对吧？
所以说啊呃大家一定要呃学以致用啊，在拉片课当中呢要熟练的运用呃灵活的调用咱们在课上学过的那些知识点，但这只是第一步。
第二步呢是学会了那些知识点以后呢，我们把它应用在应用在自己的写作当中。
所以大家记住一点啊，拉片儿课我们为什么刻意的拉不同的影片跨度大一点。上节课拉了一个肖售客的救赎好严肃啊，这节课突然拉玩具总动员了，为什么呢？待会儿我跟你讲一下，为什么拉这部片子，但是更重要的目标是什么呢？我们学会写一类影片。
我们学会学会写一类故事。
首先介绍一下这部电影，以及说一下我们为什么拉片这部电影。我告诉大家，我选这部片子的时候，我是几部片子选的啊，我自己选的。如果叫你们你选的。
绿皮书。
触不可及。
变形金刚一啊，然后。
玩具总动员仪。
我给大家讲一下啊，为什么呃这部片子呃，为什么先选了这个选题啊，因为这种双男主啊或者是类双男主，有时候是。
主体躯干和配角的关系啊。
双男主。
也未必是说这两个男主并驾齐驱，那你们能明白这个意思吧？
比如说疯狂的外星人啊，黄渤和沈腾是双男主，非常标准互补。
但是黄渤的戏份他就是多于沈腾。
你明白我意思吧？在疯狂的外星人里面。
黄牌稀饭他就是多余腾哥，懂不懂？
就是这个东西它有时候他不是说严格意义上非得是是是怎么着，伙伴之情就不能有一主一配了。伙伴之情就不能一大一小了。他凭什么呀？泰坦尼克号那也是迪卡普利奥视角，对不对啊？所以说这个东西吧，嗯不要太较劲啊？但是选这四部片子确实都是因为。
这四部片子有双男主，但是我还是强调有主次，特别是变形金刚那个大黄蜂刺的很厉害。
明白吗？有主次。所以说我想通过这四部片子告诉大家，双男主的玩法，而且双男主当中是有双男主是这样排布的，双男主是这样排布的，懂不懂啊？分类只是个简化思维。我们说一下，我们为什么这次选玩具总动员这部电影。很多同学看了可能觉得平平无奇啊。
首先这部电影是1995年出的，它有它划时代的意义啊。嗯，你现在看觉得它平平无奇很正常啊，但是当时它有划时代的意义。
首先它有个什么划时代的意义呢？
它是人类饮史上第一部。
电脑制作的三维动画长片。
也就是因为当时有电脑了啊，90年代刚有电脑，以前动画片都是迪士尼的，大家都是画出来的。但是这个皮克斯由于是个新公司。
所以他用电脑制作动画，这是第一部动画长片。
第一部电脑制作的动画电影。
所以当时这从影像风格上，或者是对业界带来的轰动和震动上。
他是非常激动的啊，非常看好。
第二，这部电影也数次斩获奥斯卡，也就是说它水平非常的高啊，数次斩获奥斯卡这个动画的导演还获得了奥斯卡终身成就奖。
第三。
这部电影的制作人是谁呢？这部电影的制片人是乔布斯。
苹果的那个乔布斯。
也就是说啊，你看啊这些技术大咖这搞电脑的这这帮人啊，我跟你说呀，他干啥啥都行。
同学们，你们有没有想过一个问题，你们给我学讲故事啊，实际上我教你们的那些东西啊，它也不止应用在写剧本里。
你们有没有想过这个问题啊？
故事这个。
讲故事的逻辑或者讲故事这些方法论在我们日常生活的方方面面都能用到。
你咱们有很多同学，你如果年轻的话啊，你跟我学讲故事学的比较早的话，我觉得对你的婚恋生活都很有帮助。同学们。
你如果你如果现在还是个年轻人，就学了我的课的话，其实对你的婚恋生活都会有帮助的。当然你要吃透了啊，你要应用在你要会扩散很或是有方法。
人家乔布斯对吧？你有没有想过他苹果手机卖的那么好，实际上他也是在讲故事。
对吧他讲了一个很好的故事。
然后呢，他的动画片做的这么好，他也是讲了一个很好的故事，懂吗？
然后这部。
电影当时那就是开山鼻祖啊，开山鼻祖嗯小成本博大票房，而且还是斩获了好多个奥斯卡。
而且啊它还是开创风格的一种电影，开创风格的一个电影。这个电影其实就像教父一样。我当时说70年代教父开创了很多风格啊，其实这个电影也是开创风格的呀。同学们在这部电影之前。
在这部电影之前。
动画片儿。
基本上都是拍给小朋友看的。
在这部动画电影之前，动画特指给小朋友看。
所以一般会伴随歌舞。
伴随很天真的爱情。
同学们。
然而这部动画片啊里面塑造恐怖元素是吧？里面塑造这个反派，里面这个把小朋友整成反派。我跟你说，这部电影在当年相当的叛逆啊，相当的叛逆。
因为90年代95年，咱们有很多同学可能95年以后才出生的啊，95年我已经记事儿了啊，我当时已经会看东京爱情故事了，所以说。
这部这种电影是划时代的啊，划时代的。
这也是为什么对吧？给大家选了这部电影，也就是说大家要认真学啊，认真学来，咱们开始吧。
开始上课啊，嗯看一部片子，我们当然会去拆解里面的类型，拆解里面的主角，拆解里面的配角，拆解里面的主题，方方面面啊都得去学，都得去研究，包括里面人家的呼应人家的伏笔，人家的道具，对吧？人家或者是我们能找出他的失误。
都得去拆解。但是。
在拆解这些之前，在你下定义之前，在你去上来就一拍板说这是什么戏，这是什么类型？这是一句话故事是什么之前别着急先给我拆信息包，因为你拆了信息包，你才有把握。
更精准的知道这是什么片子。
所以今天这部电影啊，咱们照例先拆信息包玩具总动员啊，我们说故事的开篇是从胡底的视角是吧？胡底的视角当然了，第一场肯定不是啊，第一场不是胡底视角。所以说我们拆信息包啊，基本上是按照胡底的视角拆。同学们先有个数啊，我说的主角是指。
徒弟同学们知道为什么这个片时长短吗？。
因为没钱，因为当时乔布斯还没还没做出苹果手机，他还没发财呢。
我给你看一场戏，你就知道这戏有多穷啊。everbody.
同学们。
这些。
来做客的小朋友全都长得一模一样。
因为当年啊同片要知道啊，90年代初。
当时用电脑做三维动画，要建模。
当时我跟你说，990这部片子上的时候是95年，那肯定从92年93年就开始做啊。
同学们，92年93年，你们想一想那时候的电脑是啥玩意儿啊？
那时候电脑是啥玩意儿啊？同学们。
那时候电脑是什么486586，你明白吧？
能跑得动建模，那可费了劲了。所以说你看他这些小朋友啊全都长得一模一样，来开始扒信息包。
第一场戏。
开边戏啊。
拍拍戏其实不算第一场了啊，但是它也算一个信息包啊，第一包第一分钟就是小主人在玩玩具啊，然后呢，其中有胡弟呼弟呢就是我们的主角。然后小主人说胡弟你是我最喜欢的啊，先埋下这个伏笔，埋下这个前提就是小主人在那玩玩具，这是第一包啊，第一拍第一个节拍。
然后第二个节拍第一个节拍当然是世界观啊，但是也讲了一个前提啊，主人最喜欢蝴狸啊。第二个节拍从第4分钟开始，实际上是延续第一拍。因为我们的世界观还没交代完，为什么呢？因为这部电影有个特别的地方，就是这些玩具啊都是有生命力的。
但是这个这个世界观是需要交代的，因为观众是暂时get不到的，懂吗？所以用第二拍花茶，所有的玩具都醒了，都醒了，继续展现世界观。但是呢你也不能都两拍的，还在搞世界观呀。所以所有的人物赶紧做什么做人设。
好吧，赶紧做人设啊，对吧？所有人醒过来，继续把世界观完整一下，就是告诉大家所有的小玩具都是活的，然后同时交代所有的人设，交赛团队的人设。
同时我们说还交代了胡底的领袖地位，这个很重要啊。同学们回忆一下人设都包含什么东西啊？我们说这里都是些小玩具，那肯定不存在血统问题，存在什么什么存在那个出身问题，地域问题，交代的是他们的技能缺陷，明白吗？交代的是他们的技能缺陷。
当然也交代了性格，特别胆小的恐龙，特别射牛的呃那个土豆子，忠诚于忽地的这个弹簧狗交代交代所有的。
人的技能缺陷和性格，对吧？同时最重要的当然是继续强化胡底是主人最喜欢的。所以胡底在这里是领袖。好吧，当然呃最后也轻微的点了一下胡底有个爱情线啊，就是那个牧羊女。当然了牧羊女比较悲催，后面被非常红的这个啊，芭比。
芭比娃娃这部戏火了之后，芭比娃娃就把女主角的位置抢掉了啊。但是第一季里面是牧羊女啊，牧羊女是胡迪的算是疑次爱情线啊，一次爱情线。
这是第二拍。
第三拍来到6分钟，来到6分钟，胡弟召召集大家开会，你可以理解啊，胡弟召集大家开会，这样的话可以把可以把悬念呀、目标啊都可以往外扔一扔了，招待大家开会，然后胡弟说了一个任务和时间锁，也就是。
一周以后咱们要搬家了，护迪作为领袖交代了，一周以后咱们要搬家了，一周，这是一个非常明确的时间锁啊，而且先下了咒语，就是我不想落下任何人。
我不想落下你们任何人。你看这句话一出，大家就知道要打脸了。而且这个胡迪的打脸梗说了很多，说我作为最受这个主人喜欢的这个宠物，对吧？而且我还从来不出错，我肯定会把大家都带上的。
对吧各种铺垫这一场主要是来立fl啊，第6分钟有第三趴啊，然后第四趴非常有想象力的一场戏。第四趴从第8分钟开始，生日派对是每年这些玩具最害怕的一天，因为他们有可能被取代，你看这个设计非常有意思啊，编剧非常有想象力。因为生日派对它就有可能收到新礼物嘛，收到新礼物老的礼物有可能就不受宠了吗。
所以这场戏非常有意思啊，第四拍。
呃，也就从第八分钟开始，大家就担心新玩具来，然后就开始开始第一次合作，我们叫技能展示。同学们记不记得在第一场里，如果这个戏后面有动作戏，我们会展示技能。在这里记比啊，如果记不记得我跟你们讲抢银行的戏。我说抢银行的戏动作戏。
第一第一幕在第一幕里，伙伴们登场之后，必然会展示技能。记不记得我说过这句话好，在这里正好通过这场生日派对戏大家展示技能，也就是派侦察兵呀，然后收收音机呀，然后各种。
刺探激情直播这个拆礼物的过程。
直播拆礼物的过程一直没有新玩具啊，这里又开始又做欲擒助动啊，做一个转折，一直没有新玩具，一直没有新玩具，大家就松了一口气。但是到最后一个盒子的时候没信号了，没信号了，是吧？这第四拍，第五拍，刚才那个知识点啊，技能展示这个知识点自己记在自己的本上。
第五拍从第14分钟开始，那新玩具取代了胡迪的老大位置。这一场主要讲胡迪的老大位置被新玩具给取代了，谁呀？巴次光年巴4光年啊，而且登场非常的潇洒。作为男二号，或者是大家理解为双男主。
登场极其潇洒啊，展现了他非常具有个性的人设以及他的个人目标啊，他的个人目标就是把船修好了，是吧？回到他的学回到外星。然后呢嗯但是他也有他的缺陷啊，他的缺陷就是他深信自己是一名超级英雄啊，是一个宇宙飞行员。然后这个这两个。
呃，人开始发生冲突啊，胡迪跟巴斯光剑开始发生冲突，而且呃呃在竞中在竞争中，胡迪失宠了，各种被碾压，对吧？什么那个声音，人家的声音也比它酷炫，人家有镭射，他也没有他就因为我们的这个我们这个胡迪是个提线木偶，你可以理解提线木偶比起这种装电池的玩具，那肯定。
差一个时代啊差一个时代，所以说各种被碾压。嗯甚至最后连这个巴斯光年吹牛逼的他这个会不会飞这个问题，眼看这个东西它是不可能会飞的呀，但是竟然也对吧？机缘巧合下，巴斯光年竟然也侥幸飞了起来啊，湖底被打脸啊，湖底彻底被打脸，而且彻底彻底就失宠了。
但是这里也埋下了巴斯光年狂妄侥幸的这么一个祸根。同学们记住啊，这里埋下了一个祸根。在整个电影里面，巴斯光年有三次飞行，你自己记一下。我最后告诉你飞行有什么作用？同时啊同时同同学们一定要记得啊，做这种争宠的戏也好，做这种情感戏也好。
那个小爱情啊是最有用的啊。小爱情我们说在整个电影里面，胡地的爱情线，其实我们没有着重去强调，对吧？没有着重去扑胡底和牧羊女的情感。其实铺的是胡地和巴斯光年的情感？但是为什么要做一个小爱情呢？同学们有没有想过这个问题啊？这个爱情我们既然不展开讲？
里面也没有分分合合，也没有感人的东西。我们为什么还要弄一个牧羊女在那儿跟这个狐弟好呢？为什么呢？为了刺激她跟巴斯光年的矛盾嘛，所以在这里连爱情都迷上巴斯光年了，那就完犊子了，你抢了我的位置，抢过了我主人。
抢了我的伙伴对吧？抢了我的风头，最不能忍的是连我女朋友都都觉得你更比我帅。那那忍不了了。所以说爱情啊有时候会有这个奇妙的作用，对吧？严格来说，胡迪跟牧羊女真的都都都谈不上爱情线，对吧？但是有这样奇妙的作用啊，自己记住这些知识点啊都刻在你的心里，你以后写的时候能用上。
第六拍从19分钟开始，巴斯光年彻底成为家庭的核心，家里的一切元素都围绕巴斯光年展开了。这里就是加强一下胡地的痛苦啊。因为胡迪刚才在文戏里面已经争吵占了下风了。所以从第19分钟开始用一场呃在BGM的蒙太奇啊就是。
来展现巴次光年，彻底把护狸按在地上摩擦了，好吧。
啊，带着BGM的啊。
然后很恼火之后，来到第22分钟。
22分钟，胡底跟巴斯正面开始冲突啊，正面开始冲突，讨论谁是安迪最喜欢的文具啊，感情线彻底开始崩了啊，开始崩了。两个呃两个人开始彻底开始对抗，然后胡底开始展现他小肚鸡肠的一面，咆哮巴斯光年啊，嘲讽巴斯光年。
认不清自己是个玩具这件事情啊，这也是八字光碟最大的缺陷。待会儿我们再说。然后第八拍。
我们说在很多戏里面，在第一幕会提前让反派登场，这也是个知识点。自己记一下啊。在很多戏里面第一幕提前让反派登个场啊，这样的话可以把压力做大，也就是说两个人吵着吵着发现什么了啊，发现。
隔壁那个什么发现隔壁小破孩虐杀玩具吧。我们如果假设玩具有生命，那就是虐杀玩具啊，反正就是反派提前登一下场，把他俩人的争吵打断了啊，争吵打断了。然后在这里其实还有一个重要的信息，就是巴斯光年是想出手的。巴斯光年是想出手去救助。
这个被威胁的玩具的，但是被护弟给阻挡了，被护弟给阻拦了啊，这里两个人的人设啊不断的在交代差异。好，第九拍25分钟啊，分钟数不一定准啊，因为每个版本不太一样，同学们啊，第25分钟第九拍第25分钟出现了新规则。
同学们啊，在这里啊，我们说如果主角陷入困境，那么他的目标显然是摆脱困境。但是我们说摆脱困境这个目标有点虚呀。
对吧有点虚晃，我们当然知道主角遇到困难，他想摆脱困难，对手他想杀掉对手，遇到目标，他想实现目标呢，你得给他新提示，给他新规则或者叫新提示新线索，对吧？所以在第九拍也就是25分钟这里出现了一个新线索。
呼底得知安迪。
可能是要出去吃饭还是干嘛啊，只能带一个玩具上路，你看看机会来了，咱俩争的是什么？
我们说胡迪跟巴斯争的是什么啊？争的是主人的宠爱。那么第一个新线索来了，现在要出门只能带一个玩具上路，所以说出现一个新规则，然后在这个新规则的指引下，胡迪暗算巴斯这场戏记得吧？胡迪暗算巴斯光年，结果暗算的劲儿大了，对吧？本来只想把他卡在桌子缝里，结果直接给他干失踪了，直接给他干失踪了，对吧？
呃，把闯祸了，而且胡迪这个阴谋呢被那大土豆子啊被大家给看穿了啊，看穿了。虽然胡底赖账，对吧？胡底是个小驻鸡肠的开始啊，小驻鸡肠也有点斤斤计较，所以他开始想赖账。但是嘞大家都有充分的证据围攻指责他，让胡迪成为了众矢之的啊，众矢之的。。
我们说这是第九拍啊，第十拍也就是28分钟，那主人呃胡弟暂时获得成功了啊，主人带着胡弟出门了，他获得实现了这个目标。但是巴斯光年也偷偷跟踪上路，巴斯光年偷偷跟踪上路。第1一拍来到第29分钟，巴斯光年追上了胡弟两个人打了一架啊，两动手了。
但是呢打出车外了，跟主人失联了，然后互相埋怨，互相攻击，这是肯定的。然后这时候继续强化两个人的差异跟分歧。就巴斯光年始终认为自己在拯救宇宙，回不回家的再说啊，拯救宇宙。胡迪呢说必须回家啊，因为胡迪只认主人啊，这是胡迪的特点，他只认主人。
两个人其实。
啊，待会儿再说这两个人人设人家怎么玩的啊，胡迪呢就想把巴斯光年带回家。我们说在这里你先记一笔啊，胡迪在这里想把巴斯光年带回家，开始消解他的罪恶了。你自己记一笔，后面我们讲人设的时候，这些点都要用得到啊。我们说我们营造巴斯光年不靠谱。
一定程度上不光增加了笑点，其实在消解呼底的罪恶。
因为消乎底是有原罪的，如果这是个真人电影，胡底其实会不讨喜他小肚鸡肠，他暗算别人，对吧？他又把别人给抢了别人的位置。
实际上啊狐狸会不讨喜。
我们说在这里开始消解他的罪恶了，后面还有动作啊，后面还有动作，我们待会儿再说来。
第12part，也就是第32分钟。
他们发现了新的转机，也就是一辆外卖车。然后呢，呼迪哄着巴斯上了外卖车。
上了外卖车之后。
我们说。
上了外卖车，实际上他们跟着外卖车走呗，不的在这里做了一场，巴斯虽然狂，但是呢获得了一个很好的位置。胡迪呢只能在兜里被撞得人仰马翻。我们说这场戏是什么作用啊，是不是继续在消节胡迪的罪恶？
因为为什么在这里紧急连续用好几场戏去消解胡狸的罪恶呀？
是因为我们后面开始要做这两个人成为好兄弟了，明白吧？
但是他们现在位置不平衡，因为红体刚刚坑害过巴s，而且是用很阴险的手段。你想象一下，如果是真人电影，这两个男孩子一个人用那么阴险的手段去坑另外一个人，实际上很难那么快获得观众颜料。所以这里我们需要他连续出丑。
明白吧？一呃先做好事儿，然后再出丑，连续消解罪孽啊，来到第十三趴34分钟，两个人。
追踪小主人来到了一个太空游乐场，想办法混进去啊。但是这时候巴斯光年持续误事。
持续误事啊，胡底还得找他啊，继续把胡底往上拉啊，继续把胡底往上拉。
然后第十四拍，也就是第36分钟，两个人遇到反一了啊，遇到反一了，其实就在那个抓娃娃机里嘛，两个人去在抓娃娃机里面遇到反一了，然后呼弟舍命就84，舍命就84，然后两个人一块被抓走了，一块被抓走了。
这时候，胡迪跟巴斯彻底在观众心目中应该是已经拉平了。也就是什么意思呢？胡迪在这一次舍命陪巴斯被反医抓走的这场戏里面，他的罪孽消干净了。
削干净，虽然他后面还削，我告诉你为什么，这里你就记住，在十四拍这里两个人一块被法医抓走，胡狸身上的罪孽全部消干净了。理论上我们我讲课的时候不是给你们讲过观众心理学吗？或者从观众的观影角度再研究一遍故事吗？就是在这里的时候，观众一定彻底原谅胡弟了，你要有这个信心，或者是你写的时候要有这个布局，在这里，观众彻底原谅他。
然后来到第15排38分钟，他们被反派带回家之后啊，这个反医展现出了他的极度凶残。也就是说两个人在这里陷入了绝境，陷入了一个极度的失败，极度的危险，极度的失败。因为他们想回到自己的家，现在却回到了。
恶魔的洞穴，你可以理解为是一个失败啊，是一个失败。突然发现我这里数字记错了，你们能原谅我吗？第16拍，也就是第42分钟忽底被反派折磨，他用那个呃放大镜烫他啊，被烫伤了。我刚才说过了啊。
在这场戏之前，观众已经原谅了胡迪，或者是说在这场戏之前，我们已经原谅胡迪了，对吧？那么这场戏做的是什么呢？做的是巴斯光年原谅胡迪巴斯光年原谅胡迪不能跟观众同步，必须比观众晚一步，这样才能产生情感的拉扯。同学们明白我的意思吧？
如果我们也原谅胡迪了，然后巴斯光年也在同一场戏里面原谅胡迪，那就很中规中矩，很中规中矩不带劲。必须是我们开始是埋怨胡迪的，觉得这小子真不地道。对于巴斯光年下手，虽然巴斯光年狂一点傻一点，让你吓死肉。
我们不原谅他，等我们好不容易原谅他以后呢，巴斯光年还没原谅他。所以我们在看一场胡底受苦的戏的时候，我们心里是想的是，哎呀哎呀胡底其实也没有那么哎呀呀呀哎呀，烫坏了烫坏了。
巴斯光年，你要不原谅他吧，这时候巴斯光年才原谅他，这叫拉扯观众的情绪，明白吧？
明白这场戏啊，这是第十六拍。
好，第1七拍，也就是第4分40分钟，画风突变啊，恐怖气息来袭，湖底和巴斯被这一屋子奇怪的重组玩具彻底吓坏了啊。当然了，巴斯光年还有点犯傻还有点犯傻。
也就是说他们俩来到贼窝之后，这个危机太大了啊，这是第十七拍。第十八拍切回小主人家，切回小主人家拍了一下配角团，在想办法营救主角团，就配角团在想办法这场戏其实是有用的。因为后面会用到我们说配角团前面展现了技能，展现了性格。
展现了缺陷，是不可能不用的。虽然他们从头到尾没出家门，好吧，所以说这场我们单分出来了。当然这里也有小主人回到家发现护地丢了啊，护地丢了。然后。
配角们怀疑胡迪畏罪潜逃了啊，怀疑胡弟畏罪潜逃了，这里有十8拍可以单分出来啊，我觉得可以单分出来。然后来到19拍，也就是第43分钟左右啊，胡迪和巴斯找到机会可以逃跑了啊，这是一场大的动作戏，两个人找到机会可以逃跑了，冲破各种障碍呀、恶犬呀。
对吧两个人虽然在争吵，但是被迫合作呀，对吧？两个人终于合作了嘛，在这里记着啊，十九拍两个人才第一次真正的合作啊，前面只是一个人拖另外一个人后后腿，或者谁救谁。在第19拍43分钟这里才开始在争吵中被迫合作啊，在这里啊在这里。
估地的失误弄醒了恶犬。
我们说诶，为什么又是胡地的失误了？
同学们。
在这里啊，胡底的失物把恶犬弄醒了，为什么是乎当然是无心，他那个瓜住了，他是个提线木偶嘛？我们说提现木偶是他的一个缺陷，对吧？他是个老老式玩具，提现木偶我们说他这个缺陷在关键时刻给自己带来了攻击对吧？缺陷攻击嘛，攻击缺陷嘛，在关键时刻攻击缺陷了。
为什么是公鸡的狐狸呢？
是因为前面犯傻的一直是巴斯呀，不可能再让巴斯犯傻了。我们观众已经彻底原谅胡迪了，而且有点可怜他呢，他刚被整过，所以该胡迪犯错了，明白吧？但是这时候啊这时候巴斯在干什么呢？有同学说该巴斯表现了，巴斯彻底没有任何表现。
在同一场里在同一拍里，发斯通过电视发现了自己的最大缺陷。也就是说他以前最大缺陷是狂妄啊，是认不清自己，是以为自己是世界英雄，他在这一场里发现了自己就是个玩具，对吧？原来我根本就不帅。
然后非常低落，让你们记一下巴斯的三次飞行啊。
这里啊巴斯的第二次飞行，他试飞吧，在非常低落的情况下试一下自己到底能不能飞。
失败。
而且。
胳膊摔断。
给我水吧？
然后第二0拍。
第20part，也就是第47分钟。
巴斯对吧？巴斯被反医的妹妹给拿走了，控制了啊，呼迪再去营救巴斯。但是巴斯受刺激过度已经疯了啊，已经疯了。然后。
这时候开始出现刚才铺垫配角团吧，21拍也就四十几五分钟这里。
胡底向老友们求助，但是大家却对他更误会了，发现那个巴斯的断臂了吗，他们以为彻底误会，胡底杀死了巴斯，拒绝帮助他啊，弄巧重拙，众叛齐离啊，众叛亲离啊，一定要记住，这里众叛亲离。然后第22分钟。
啊，第22拍52分钟，这里恐怖的这些虫组玩具啊，并不是什么坏人啊，发现他们并不是什么坏人，只是虚惊一场。他们甚至帮巴斯接好了胳膊。
但是高高出现一个小的利好，第23拍马上再打下去53分钟。这个反译啊要用炮仗炸掉这个巴斯光年。嗯，而且在这里啊，由于巴斯光年已经疯了，所以他再次做了一个胡底的愧疚。因为他本来想选胡底，结果胡迪躲了一下，就选中了巴斯光年。我们说这一招啊反复可以用啊。
同学们一定记住啊，制造主角的负罪感，制造主角的原罪，实际上可以反复用啊，反复用，反复消减才能有趣嘛。特别是刷男主的时候啊，因为两个男孩之间，你其实很难去做那些矫情的戏，倒不如做这种戏啊，同学们待会儿我们讲细节的时候，大家自己再学一学。
由于户籍躲了一下啊，我们可以看一眼啊。
这种小小的一些小小小消解的一些戏。
其实是挺有意思的。
他本来想炸掉胡地，胡地躲在这里。当然胡弟没有任何的错，因为他只是想保护自己，但是他的无心的行为导致了巴斯光年要被炮仗炸掉。因为他不知道他这样做。
对。
明白吧？同学们一定要学着啊，一定要学着，你看啊这样去制造主角的愧疚，我们观众是不会怪他的，明白我这意思吧？因为在都已经到故事的第三幕了，中后期了，你如果再去制造主角有意愧疚，那就完蛋完蛋了，那就捞不回来了，明白吧？记自己记一下啊。
在故事的中后期，你为了增加两个人人物感情的拉扯、厚度以及剧情的紧张感，我们可以再次制造主角的愧疚感，但是没有必要让他像故事开始那样故意使坏了。
因为你这时候如果还故意，比如说小主人那个那个坏人本来想选我炸掉，然后我故意躲在巴斯光年后面把巴斯光年推出去，那就完蛋了。同学们在这个位置，那就完蛋了。我们没有篇幅再去把它捞回来了，捞不回来了，对吧？
所以说啊这里它是一个不小心啊不小心。然后同时选中八次光年之后，由于下雨了，设定一个时间锁。同学们，这里设定时间锁设定了多么的时间锁啊。同学们记得吧？我说时间锁是个比喻，就是增加紧迫感。在这个电影里面时间锁这是个时间锁呀。
设了个闹钟。
对不对？设了个闹钟，所以说这有时候也是够直白啊。有时候这些美国电影啊也是够直白的。
然后设了一个时间锁，当然了，跟之前的那个一星期之后搬家形成双重时间锁啊。呃在2十三拍这里，巴斯光年身上被绑的这个窜天猴是本剧的最大危机啊。本戏的最大危机，也就是死亡危机啊。我们说第二3拍巴斯光年身上这个炸弹已经到了这个窜天猴已经到了灵魂黑夜了。
然后那二4拍另外一个时间锁，此时不用，更待何时，对不对？另外一个安迪马上要搬走的那个时间锁，马上也要给一下子呀。
懂不懂啊？
明白吧？也就说这里是最要劲儿的时候，灵魂黑夜了，打到谷底了。你巴斯光年身上被绑子残天猴了，对吧？八4光年人生要破灭了，狐底最在意的是什么啊？胡底最在意的是他的小主人。所以说这里二4拍干到底第25拍。
也就是第55分钟，双男主由于分别被束缚了自由，两人开始灵魂交谈啊，灵魂交谈。
我其实讲过啊。
那个主角被打入谷底，经历过灵魂黑夜之后，怎么振作起来来着找个地方舔舐伤口是吧？重新解读，重新思考，然后发挥潜能。这里就是字面意义上的两个人就是灵魂交谈，互相激励，好吧，字面意义上啊，呃，同学们一定要理解。
第一，这是95年的片子。第二呢，这是个动画片。第三，这个片子只有70分钟出头啊，所以说这里确实略微草率了。
哎，给你们看一看这样草率的戏，就是两个男主角重新振作起来。
about me。
You should get out of here while you can.
。
What you doingCom on there's a kid over that house get out.
We can do it.
什么病这样。
哎，爱妈帮我什么呢？
嗯。
不。
也从侧面证明了一件事情，就是话疗啊确实在早期的电影里面啊应用的比较比较多。但是我们要理解一个什么事情啊，为什么早期的电影用化疗用比较多啊，因为人家地其他地方没用这么多话疗，灵活运用啊，灵活运用挺好的啊，来记个知识点啊，记个知识点。
同学们一定要记着啊，呃这里不光是写台词，呃，你人生当中劝别人也是这样啊，你不断的夸他怎么好，夸他怎么那个实际上是很难劝好他的。你只有剖析你自己展现你还不如他，他才会振作起来啊。呃，这个台词是这么写。你生活当中你要劝别人，或者你要说服别人，也是这样。
也是这样，你从他的角度一直说一直说，因为他他的事情他比你了解，所以你光夸他好没有用，你得说我孬，你看我更傻，我小时候还不如你呢，啥啥啥，他这马上他就开心了啊，优越感就起来了。所以说生活当中嗯这个说服别人啊，这些招都可以应用啊。同学们这里是题外话啊。
题外话来第26趴第58分钟。